Hildur go to school something cute I'm
Colson Baker and here are my essentials
cold brew because my eyes probably don't
open without them
[Music]
it was hot coffee this morning because I
walked eight blocks to get this cold
coffee so I needed something hot to get
me on the walk back and then it's cold
coffee when I want to enjoy and sit here
and really actually taste the coffee I'm
really huge on what kind of beans they
use or what kind of caffeine how I'm
gonna get and I also have a coffee
lounge opening a 20-19 stuff it's like
research right Gucci bag
I travel with it everywhere I love the
bold red it's like a cabinet and
throughout my day I like to just throw
things in the cabinet there's a little
lot make sure no one gets here [ __ ] when
I get on a plane usually the first thing
I do is whip this out my friend maybe a
blanket from our birthday says for those
who soon and then it says rest up on the
tombstone so that's what I rest my head
on every day appropriate I'm digging the
smells this is like an incense holder
that I use everywhere I go sometimes
it's to mask the smell of whatever I'm
smoking in my hotel room other times
like whenever I'm at my trailer doing a
movie
I'll have that lit gift from Sandra
Bullock cool fact do you have a lighter
I didn't choose the scent this was
actually Sandy's choice she gifted me
this and a bunch of bags of green tea
because she was worried that I drank too
much coffee
ironically oh I guess I just had a
really good time filming this movie it's
called burn box I'm gonna just reminds
me of the movie I guess I'm big on
reading one highest reading with a book
currently I'm reading just kids by Patti
Smith she's also an awesome musician and
I read a lot of comics so like this
one's
I was waiting in line at this place
called blue genome cafe by my house
you know until they called my name I'll
just walk around I'd smoke and I'd like
I popped in this comic book store and I
asked the guy like does it get deeper
than conventional superhero comics like
because there's some stuff for your mind
or what kind of alter your views on life
like go into a fantasy place that like
means something and they pointed out a
couple when I read on and I fell in love
and every time I went got breakfast I
would just buy like five to six hundred
dollars worth of comics like every trip
I write all the time I'm like notebooks
that people give me so I sometimes fans
will give me like gnarly design ones
other one this one I just did three
different Netflix movies and this they
gave me like a bunch of gifts but the
notebook was read sometimes I like
fashion ideas you know is what I want on
shirts like a grandma like shirt things
I was like fighting and being on a
17-hour flight like sketching ideas
don't say I didn't warn you
razor blade I like to work for things so
even if it's like a shave I was want to
feel like I had to work for it I keep
like keep one of these if I want to go
clean face I can't meditate I'm not
there and like that so like if I can
extend my shave from like five minutes
to 15 minutes and like do it right and
play good music and stuff then maybe
that's like my little meditation
meditation like I said I'm thinking the
smell so this is one I really love the
oil contents really high which we use a
little to stick on you longer it's cool
cuz you can customize it so it says for
machine gun okay I'm huge I'm Cologne
I've got this motley crew movie coming
out my friend who plays opposite of me
I'm playing Tommy Lee and he plays Nikki
Sixx he had the special clone they
thought it was cocaine cigarettes and
something else and that's like what this
scent was supposed to smell like and you
smell it and it smelled just like that I
wouldn't know but
I'm like back in like he didn't know my
brain sometimes mode you know so like
I've been waiting for this to come out
since I was probably like 12 or whatever
the last time I played this on my n64
was I'm like classic I like Smash Bros I
like Zelda Mario Tennis is fire on here
the passport holder travel out the
country all the time I also don't have a
driver's license it got taken away from
me so this is my only form of ID this is
my sixth passport I've been warned that
I will not be issued another one if I
lose this so I have a tile thing to
always make sure that I find it and it
is not in here so I don't know what
happens if you lose the tile that's
supposed to keep every hotel room in and
everywhere I go I promote arts have a
guitar this one was actually just given
to me from Schechter who also designs
like Princeton's guitars they burned
this in there
I remember going to consciousness the
kid and when a band I'm gonna throw a
pic in the crowd and like you'd get it
it would be like a custom pick and oh my
god this is so cool man I can't wait
till I grow up and get to make my own
pick I can throw somebody and they look
at it and be like oh so this is that I
remember this was like a series we did
when I toured Australia so like only
people in Australia have this big double
X is like our family crest you know for
like the band and for our gang I guess
standard machine ok ok all right that
was one more essentials thank you guys
for watching catch me at the next show
maybe I'll throw one of these
[Music]